[موسيقى]
لحظات قليله وتبدا اصعب المواجهات ضمن
الحلقه الثانيه من التصفيات خلكم
معانا
[موسيقى]
k
السلام عليكم مشاهدي نجوم العلوم ومحبيه
عبر اختلاف مواسم وحياكم الله على شاشه
الام بي سي ف ماذا لو جمعنا كل المعلومات
على هذا الكوكب في وعاء واحد له القدره
على التنقل في كل مكان هذا ابتكار يبدو
شبه مستحيل الا انه اصبح حقيقه متطوره مع
ما نسم اليوم بتكنولوجيا المعلومات مجال
ابتكارات اليوم يركز على هذه التكنولوجيا
العظيمه اليكم لجنه تحكيمها في هذا
[موسيقى]
التقرير انها حلقه التصفيات الثانيه
والحماس لا يزال في اوجه توح بتجنن اخيرا
اليوم ستارف سينس انا كان بجم
العلوم المزيد من المشتركين يتوافدون الى
واحه قطر للعلوم والتكنولوجيا وابتكاراتهم
ستهبط على رؤوس الحكام من فضاء الحوسبه
وتكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]
المعلومات في الحلقه الماضيه البروفيسور
فؤاد والسيده عائشه اختار ابتكارات بارزه
في مجال الصحه وعلوم الطب الحيوي بمساعده
البروفيسور زهيري انا وياك واحد اثنين لا
مهمه ستقع هذه المره على عاتق العضو الضيف
الخبير في مجال الحوسبه وتكنولوجيا
المعلومات لاختيار افضل الابتكارات في
مجاله انه الدكتور احمد ل مجرمت المدير
التنفيذي لمعهد قطر لبحوث
الحوسبه في عننا قطاع اسمه تكنولوجيا
المعلومات والاتصالات انا متكل بالتعاون
مع الدكتور احمد زميلي جديد بلجنه التحكيم
نختار افضل من يتاهل المرحله الثانيه كنت
مسؤول على التنميه واختيارات مشاريع
وتكنولوجيا لاكثر من 30 سنه انا عارف انه
في العلوم الحيويه اختاروا 8 مشاريع واحنا
في تقنيه المعلومات مش حنختار اقل من
ع القهوه تحضر ورائحه البن تفوح في اجواء
لؤلؤه قطر اليوم بدك تساعدنا نقدر نعمل
تصنيف ومين اللي فعلا عامل كونتربيوشن قمه
بمجال العلمي بالاي سي تي في افكار فيها
نوع من الاورجينال التي بس احنا نحاول قدر
الامكان ان يكون الاختيار موفق ما بين
التجاري والعلمي
يلا ماما من المتاخرين عن الموعد السيده
عائشه وليست بمفردها والله اليوم معال
شويه بس عشان يشمون هوا ان شاء الله ما
يصير وايد
ازعاج يلا ز ب نروح نشوف بعدين بشوفك
انزين يلا شاطره انت
[موسيقى]
صح السلام عليكم السلام ورحمه طيبين
تفضلوا تفضلوا الله يخليكم سوري شوي تاخرت
لان اليوم يبتلي معي اه اليوم معك الاولاد
ايوه طبعا الاطفال دائما اوديهم معي
المكتب يعني اذا معودين يعني خلص كل اللي
في المكتب متعودين وهم عم يكبروا بجو
العمل ايوه والمكتب ايوه ف الحين بنتي
تعرف اذا بتروح النيرسري مرات تقوم الصبح
تقول ابي اروح الشغل ما تبي تروح
[موسيقى]
النسري دكتور احمد كيف عيلتك عندي خديجه
وخليفه لسه ما وصلوا الجامعه في المدرسه
الثانويه لانه هلا الشباب والصبايا بيعوا
بكثره الاختصاصات
والتكنولوجيات خليفه مائل اكثر للنور سينس
وخديجه اكثر في الهندسه والرياضيات وطالعه
لابوها طالها وخليفه طالعه لامه هي دكتوره
كمان ام دكتوره اه ما شاء الله ف انتم
يعني امنتم استمراريه
الاختصاصات ومن المستثمرين في رحله
الابتكار خالد ابو جسوم وابتكاره طاهي
ينضم الى طاوله الكبار ان شاء الله اكون
وه خير على لجنه الحكم احس القاعده الحين
بتختلف قبل انا مشترك الحين انا مثل ما
تقولون زميل مع لجنه الحكم ان شاء الله بس
دكتور مراد ما يكون وايد حامي
يعني خالد منيح هذا مثل من الاعمال
التطبيقيه
ب انت بتعرفني منيح ايوه وبكا كنت اسال
اسئله محرجي لقلب نعم صحيح بس بعدين بعد
ما ترجت حبيتني وحبيت الاسئله يعني نعم
صحيح تقدر تقول نعم هي علاقه الحب العلاقه
العلاقه ايه علاقه الحب يعني قاعده تطور
خلنا نقول يا قنا بس اعطينا نعطيك التركس
هذا هل عننا صنع في قطر الطريقه الاليه
لتحضير الطعام الصحي مازلنا مركزين على
طاهي كجهاز حصلنا دعم من بنك قطر للتنميه
من نجوم العلوم النموذج كان نموذج لاثبات
الفكره كان مركز على التقنيه والتكنولوجيا
واثبات هلم بس انتنا جدنا اكل منه انا
اكلت كان الاكل
يكل في طبخه
الان معقول نوصل انه ندوق شي طيب معقول
جاهزه
للاكل هو شنو كان الفيدباك حقك انا بقول
لك كان طعام لذيذ كيف كن عم استطعم بالرز
مش انه مثل هذا اكل المستشفيات المخبو مش
اوفر كوك ات واز يعني على القد هيك القد
و
بنتك تي فرلي
يعني ما عننا في الشغل وتشوف الانتز ع
الوم جا تحكم جاي يتحكم معنا اليوم ولا شو
يلا تبين تحكمين معنا ماما حبيبي هلا في
بعض المشاركين لازم اعرفها عليهم وانا ما
بدي اخر ولا دقيقه لانه حمستوني اكثر
اتعرف على ه المبتكرين اليوم بمجال
المعلوماتيه وتكنولوجيا الاتصالات يلا
توكلوا
علىيه لا لا معي معي زملاء لطيفين رح
يساعدوهم بس اكيد رح يكونوا كمان صارمين
لانه برنامج علمي ما هيك بال يهمك بس احنا
حنحاول
نرطب
شويه جلسه عائليه بامتياز بين الحكام
وافراد العائله الواحده قد يختلفون قريبا
على ارث
الابتكارات
ماذا يعني عالم دون تكنولوجيا المعلومات
يعني ان ترموا هواتفكم وان تحذفوا
حساباتكم عبر مواقع التواصل وان تغلقوا
حواسب المحموله ولكن لن تتجر على اطفاء
تلفاز ف الابتكارات في هذا المجال واعده
وس نعرضها عليكم
حالا في هذه الحلقه الخاصه بالحوسبة
[موسيقى]
وغيرها شخصيه معروفه تعود لتفاجئ الجميع
ضربات تايكواندو في الاستوديو مشترك يتحدى
اللجنه بحل المكعب في 30 ثانيه واللجنه
كالعاده لا ترحم
[موسيقى]
احدا احمد نعم تفضل شو هو الاختراع اللي
جاي يتعرض علينا فكره المشروع الزم سائق
السياره على لبس حزام الامان لسلامه
الشخصيه وسلامه الركاب معه مثل ما نعرف
بانه في بعض السيارات في الصوت هذا البيبس
يظل يرن لمده ثواني ال دقيقه فكره مشروعي
بانه شلون اجبره بانه يلبس حزام الامان
اعرض صوره على الزجاجه الاماميه واجهه
السياره وعند لبس حزام الامان تختفي
الصوره عرض شاشه قدام
السائق انت ساق من الدحه ولا جاي من
العراق لا والله من العراق جاي من العراق
ت تخبرنا هالفكره والله هذا الموجود مرحبا
اهلا وسهلا
فيك حابب تزور الدوحه انت عجبتك الحمد لله
وكنت حاطط سيت بلت كل الوقت سيم كارت طبعا
سيت بلت تبعك كنت حاط حزامان اكيد طبعا
حزام الامام بالعربي اسمه سي دلد
بالانجليزي صح صحيح نبلش
هونك وين الاختراع هو مو اختراع فكره ونحن
عم نبرع
مع فكره ولا اختراع شو رايك اختراع طبعا
بس انا مشروع عندي وع
طيب شو رايكم نربح شويه وقت وثلاث نصوت له
و ونقول له استمتع بما بقي لك في الدوحه
قبل ان ترجع الى العراق ماش شكرا
احمد سيضع حزام الامان وينطلق في طرقات
الدوحه
للتنزه لكن سحمه السير قد تكون مشكله
والحل في الابتكارات
الاتيه فكره
لاداره الحركه المروريه للتخلص من بعض
الازدحامات المروريه الاكثر تكرارا عن
طريق نظام تحكم ذكي تخطيطات مضيئه لاب
لاين يكون عباره عن اضويه ليدز بدك تغير
الخطوط على الارض كلها تصير ليدز وتتغير
لونها على طول الهاي طول
الها وتغير اوتوماتيكي حسب الترافيك اوما
وتصبح وتصبح حوادث كارثيه في
[موسيقى]
نعملها مثل ما قالك دكتور احمد يعني هو
صحيح بكون اختراع بس اختراع كارثه
بدك تطالب انه الشعب يريد تغيير نظام
السير تعرف انه اشارات السير والسر كله
يحكم عن طريق اشارات الضوئيه هون عندك
اشارات ضوئيه بس مش عموديه افقيه شو بدك
انت ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
خطر اتبت انه انا لا اشارك افكاري
النيره المهمه الا شخصيا لانه فزعان ما ح
لك الملكيه الفكريه هك عندك شيء كثير مهم
حريص عليه ان شاء الله ب نشوف اذا بوفك
الراي انا هلا الابتكار تاعي بختص للانتر
سكشن والزحمه اللي بصير بالانتر سكشن بدنا
نخفف اليشن اللي بوقف عليها على الاشاره
الحمراء بالضبط نخففه باستخدام ان شاء
الله الابتكار بس هو اكيد الابتكار تاعي
شوي مطور شوي مطو حاليا في حل ما بعرف الا
لسه اليوم عرفته انه يزيدوا سعر البترول
ف يقللوا عدد
السيارات ف
هلا الابتكار
هلا للاسف ما في ابتكار
بديل انت شو
اختراعك ما في ابتكار بديل للحظه هي لانه
ما حطيته انا بالاخضر لانه مش متاكد
منه بس هو هلا الحاليا المتوفر حاليا انه
هيك مثلا هي عدد الفيز اللي بتكون هون بس
الفكره يعني زي ما بتقول اكثر شي اللي هي
هون انه تكون عننا ال انترسكشن يقدر يتحول
من الفيز العاديه الاربعه مثلا يقدر يحول
مثلا لتو فيز بس طيب لحظه واللي بده يروح
يمين وشمال تعطله برزه ما له
خيار وينك يش انت بخليه نمل يعني هي
مفكرها ه مش نمل هون مش صير بتقلهم كلكم
بتروحوا هيك ب خيارات ب يعمل شمال يمين
كيف هذا هو الاختراع هذا هو
الاختراع نعم حاولت تعمل تركس علينا وفي
وما في ولزقه ما بعرف مين صحك فيها ه
الطريقه هيدي الفشله بس نن
مم نضيف مثلا بدي اياك تضيف شي بدي تضيف
على راسك
هلون
شكرا شايف ش اشه توقيت ثلاثه حمر بنفس
الوقت في هيدي اختراع يح هون موفق شكرا
نست يعني ام سوري بس يعني ها حتى فكره مش
فكره كل المحاولات فشلت لحل مشكله الزحمه
وسنبقى عالقين بها الى ان ياتي من
يخلصنا انظروا من وصل من يكون هذا العائد
الى نجوم العلوم شايفه كذا مره على يوتيوب
يمكن شايفه قبل بالبرنامج لل المبخره
مضبوط انه خالد وهو اشهر من ان يعرف فكلنا
نعرفه صار واحد من نجوم نجوم العلوم خالد
ما شاء الله شخصيه مثابره يعني وهذه
محاولته السابعه على التوالي في نجوم
العلوم اخر موسم شاركت فيه موسم السالس
اول ما دخلت على اللجنه يعني عملوا لي مثل
احتفال بسيط يعني انت مشارك معنا من عمر
برنامج نجوم العلوم اي نعم لك هابي
بيرثدي هاي بيرث
كان فكره ابتكار مبخره ذكيه ولكن هذا
الموسم انا غيرت الفكره بحيث ان ان شاء
الله باذن الله اني اوصل الى التسعه
المقبولين اللي يدخلوا في برنامج نجوم
ويلكم
باك بدي اعرفكم عليه يعني فيني قد ما صار
جاي سنين فيني اقوله زميلي خالج في
البرنامج انت اسك 23 ايو 2و قدامك كثير ان
شاء في عننا سنوات جديده الله رات نوصل
للحد
طيب ليك انت صرت تعرف يعني رح توخر علي
الاسئله اي نعم اكيد صرت تعرف شو بسال
اكيد بقى سؤال وجاوب معك عش داهيه خلاص ان
شاء الله تفضل فكره المشروع و فكره
الابتكار هي جاتني عن طريق مشكله انا
شخصيا اعانيها هي الفكره بشكل عام تحل
مشكله بعد انصراف الطلاب في انتهاء الدوام
المدرسي ولي الامر لما يجي طبعا يكون او
المدرسه بعد انصراف الطلاب ازدحام شديد
طبعا امام المدرسه ولي الامر يوصل للمدرسه
فيوقف سياره ينتظر ولده يجي يعني تكون في
مشكله الطلاب يكونوا منتشرين ح سور
المدرسه وبعض الاحيان لا سمح تحدث حوادث
سير اوغيره فالمشكله اللي انا حاب احلها
كيف هي عباره عن نظام سيستم عباره عن فون
ابلكيشن وشاشه موجوده في المدرسه كيف تتم
العمليه انت كولي امر قبل عن ما توصل
المدرسه بمسافه نص كيلو الابلكيشن الفون
ابلكيشن راح يرسل اشاره الى ال سي دي
الشاشه الم موجوده في ساحه المدرسه ويكون
يوضح له رقم معين بالتالي ابنك راح يشوف
رقم واحد راح يعرف انه امري خلاص واصل فهو
مجرد انهيك يروح البوابه خلاص انت اول ما
توصل راح تاخذ ابنك وتروح بك بشكل سريع
زميلي الدكتور احمد خبير اتصالات وحوسه
بده يسالك تفضل دكتور
ا وخبير تربيه
اولاد هذ مع
خليفه انا صانع الازمات مع خليفه ابني هذه
ما تمشي السيستم لان وقت ما تجيه تاخذه هو
تذكر لعب مع اصحابه و يتاخر اي هو في
ابلكيشن موجوده في حلول موجوده في
نفسين في نفس الدومين يعني لكن اليه العمل
هي اللي تختلف انا الاليه العمل اللي
حطيتها هي هي مناسبه لمدارس
الموجده في كذا ابلكيشن حيكي وحده بنيو
هامشير عندي في التلفون جربت انت مختلف عن
بمختلف عنه في اختلافات كثيره في مره خط
ضوء اخضر
مني في الموسم الرابع
[ضحك]
انا حابب نقشك بالمجلس العلمي شخصيا اكرك
دكتور شكرا
جزيلا انا اقول موفق ان شاء الله مره
تانيه يا سيدي عائشه الحسم لك هلا
فعلا احتدمت الامور وصار القرار
عندك
يعني
تق تكون احسن
مجبل بس بنعطيك فرصه وكل التوفيق شكرا
واخيرا مبروك م دكتور شكرا شكرا
دب
يسلمك شكرا يس مبروك الف
[تصفيق]
مبروك يعني خمس
سنوات
بروجرام فكره مفيده لخالد لكن حل مشكله
سحمه امام مداخل المدارس ليست من اولويات
الطلاب هواتفهم الذكيه ونتائج فحوصاتهم هي
الاهم وقد حضروا شخصيا لحلها مع
اللجنه كنت احضر نجوم العلوم اتوقع من
الموسم الخامس كنت حابب اني اشترك من ذيك
الفتره ولكن شروط البرنامج ما تسمح دخول
من تحت 18
سنه تعديت ال 18 سنه والان انا اصغر مشترك
في برنامج نجوم
العلوم اول شي هو الاختراع هو هو حل مشكله
سقوط الجوال وانكسار الشاشه انه لما يسقط
الجوال فيبدا يطلق الموجات الفوق صوتيه من
الجوال اهتزازات اللي تصدرها تضرب على سطح
الارض وبعدها ترتد الى الجوال يعني بيوقع
التلفون على الارض بس بصير سوفت
[موسيقى]
لاندين انه بصير في سوفت لاندين بديل ما
يكون ايه ايه يمتص الضربه
فيفرغ يخففها بجزيئات الهواء يد الضربه
انت شو دارس بدي احكي انا وياك انا خريج
ثانويه خريج ثانويه عمري 18 سنه تون متخرج
من الثانويه انا اصغر مشترك هنا 18 سنه ما
شاء الله العمر كله ان شاء الله ما شاء
الله ارقام وبكيل بتقب لك هذا الاختراع
على الزباله بتعرف شو زباله يعني
[موسيقى]
القمامه تدرس فيزياء ولا اي تدرس في
المستقبل علوم سياسيه ان شاء الله بس حاول
تدرس فيزياء ما تدرس ب انا دارس فيزياء
دارس لا لا الان في الجامعه يعني يعني
لازم اخذ الدكتوراه حتى ابتكر لا ما تبتكر
بس الاقل جامعه دكت بالجامعه شايف هذا
الضوء المضو قدامي ايه انا شايف هذا عازل
بيني وبينك عازل اوكي انا عندي ميول
للهندسه ولكن عندي اكثر الحين اكتشفت انه
عندي ميول العلوم السياسيه
[موسيقى]
اكثر تفضلي شو الاختراع الجيد ترحيه على
اللجنه اليوم الفكره هي عباره عن المم هذا
القلم الكتروني اللي بيستخدمه
المصححين في المدارس بعمليه التصحيح هذا
القلم مكون من كاميرا في راس القلم ها
الكاميرا بتشعر الارقام من صفر ل اللي
حيكتب المعلم مثلا السؤال الاول نفترض
مثلا انه عليه مثلا خمس علامات فعلى
المعلم انه اذا كان كله صح يكتب خمس
علامات السؤال الثاني ثلاث علامات كتب
ثلاث علامات وهيك
وين ايه القلم لما بيستخدم هو عم يكتب
العلامه رح يجمع له اوتوماتيكيا كل
الارقام وبعدين مثلا بكبسه زر بيعطيه
النتيجه النهائيه هو ما عليه غير انه
يكتبها على الورقه نحن علمنا وصلح وبنعرف
دي يعني ابسط ابسط جهد التصليح هي حل
هالمشكله وابسط شيء هي هو عم يشرب قهوه
بيجمع العلامات اخر شيء طيب انا بدي اعتذر
منك ما اقتنعت في
[موسيقى]
اختراع الفشل ليس في الحصول على علامات
سيئه في الاختبار انما الفشل يكون في عدم
المحاوله من جديد علي الصليطي يعود الينا
في محاوله
[موسيقى]
ثانيه اسمي علي خالد من قطر ادرس في ولايه
كاليفورنيا بجامعه وود بيري هندسه معماريه
السنه اللي فاتت شاركت في برنامج نجوم
العلوم وكان ابتكاري اكلم عن السينما
المتنقله بدك تضو خضر من اصل لاثه والا
بتروح تحضر سينما
لوحدك خسرت لكن هالشي ما خلاني يعني اتحبت
بالعكس حمسني وخلاني اجي ه السنه بابتكار
افضل وان شاء الله اقنع لجنه الحكام وافوز
بالمرحله الاولى باذن
الله فكرتي عباره عن عمليه اوتوماتيكيه
تحول رسومات من 2 دي الى 3 دي طبعا معروف
ان تصميم مجسم ثلاثي الابعاد ياخذ ساعات
طويله وهذه من الاسباب اللي تخلي شركات
افلام الكرتون تاخذ اربع الى خمس سنوات
عشان تنتج مجرد فيلم
واحد ابتكاري عباره عن عمليه اوتوماتيكيه
تحول الرسومات من تو دي الى 3 دي بدقه
عاليه باستخدام لغه البرمجه والحسابات
الدقيقه وحركه الجسم عبر محور اكس واي زد
والله يعني
اهداف ممتازه وانت شاركت معنا قبل بسنه ما
هيك نعم وانا يعني فخور فيك انك عم تشارك
عن
جديد صرت مستعد اكثر م يعني نفعتك
المشاركه الماض فدتني كثير حاسك هلا عم
تحكي بثقه وبتعرف شو الحمد لله انت حق من
يعني من الكستمر مالك من من العميل اللي
راح يستخدم ه شركات افلام الكرتون كرت
اي هو المره الماضيه شو كانت فكرتك اللي
شاركت فيها سينما متنقله يعني هو مركز على
هوايتي انا في الاشياء هوايت الافلام بده
ياخذ هنيش افلام في المستقبل راح يكون
عندي شركه افلام من عندي يعني من انتاجي
انا مش افلام من برا يعني اخذها من برا لا
متاكد انه افلامك شيقه جدا ان شاء الله
هلا الدكتور احمد اختصاصه شو كمبيوتر
ساينس بقى حظك منيح تفضل علي والله انا
شايف حتى رياضيا في صعوبه لانك انت عندك
جيومتري كيف الزاويه يعني مش شايف انه هو
بسيط يعني لا سهل انك تسويها بده يروح
لعند المبرمجين الخبراء بمركز الدكتور
احمد ويقول لهم تعوا اعملوا لي هيك
صحك لازم تعطيهم الور يعني لا ب يقوللهم
انتم شغلتكم الجورم شو شغلته شغله بس اكيد
انا اخذ من خبرتهم ياخذوا من خبرتي بعد
انا استعملت يعني شوف كيف يعني العلم
وليش لا ليش لا هلا ببرنامج نجم العلوم
بصراحه ما في شرط بقول هو لازم
يعمله نحن اذا اعتبرنا انه هذا اختراع
واجباتنا نامن الخبراء يشتغلوا معك هدي
شروط البرنامج انت بتعرف الشروط ما وضحت
الصوره اي وضحت الصوره وبالنسبه لي انا مش
مقتنعه
شكرا انا بقول انه علي اللي
مقترحه برمجيا صعب جدا
ممكن
ومهم ولازم نشوف كيف بدنا نجربه انا مع
انه ناقش بالمجلس العلمي ونشوف كيف بدنا
نترجمه لصنعه في قطر من هنا لعند المجلس
العلمي حنعمل انشن
اكثر عان نكون انا مقتنع عن هذا حصير
من ضو اخضر
مبروك الحمدله الله يجزاك الخير يعطيكم
العافيه تفضل يم الايف ابشرك يما ابشرك
فزنا فزنا
ي
فزنا الحمدلله يب الحمدلله طيب ربما علي
ان اعترف ان ليست كل الابتكارات واعده في
هذا المجال ولكن لربما الافضل ياتي بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
عدنا اليكم محبي التكنولوجيا والتواصل
وانتم كثر نعي حضوركم عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الخاصه بنجوم العلوم اليكم الان
المزيد من
الابتكارات اسمي بدر عبد الله ابو زيد من
السعوديه فكره المشروع هي استخدام مياه
الايس كنديشن في الري في دورات المياه في
الغسيل وفي استخدامات كثيره ثانيه انا
اتمنى اني اقابل الدكتور فؤاد واخذ افكاره
بالعكس حتى انتقاداته الحاده حتكون
بالنسبه لي ممتازه بدر انت جيبنا اختراع
هيك شوي
مميز ان شاء الله تكون انت مميز مثل
اختراعك ان شاء الله شو الاختراع وكيف
بيشتغل الفكره هي استخدام تقنيه المياه
اللي بتخرج من الاير كونديشن وتوجيهها
للاماكن ال حيحه لها اللي هي الري مياه
الزينه وغيرها كثير فاللي بيصير انه احنا
بناخذ هذه المياه بنحط في خزانات بس انت
شو عمل جديد يعني انت انت عامل حمله توعيه
تتقول لهم للناس استعملوا هذه المي اللي
بتطلع من المكيفات واستعملوها بالرا مثلا
الفكره مش انها تصير عمليه توعيه الفكره
انها يتم استخدام هذه التقنيه لانه للاسف
ما في تنظيمات هيئات بتخلي الشركات الكبرى
المص هذا هو اختراعك بالضبط نعم انا من
هلا بقوللك انت منك بنجوم العلوم وهذا
الضو الاحمر ستوب انا كثير متضايق منك انك
تدعي نفسك انك مخترع انا ما ادعت ان انا
مخترع مدعي انك مختر وشو جاي لهون
تعمل لك فكره منيحه وقهم الناس يستعملوها
وع يستعملوها وعطشت قد ما حكيت على المي
ومنو اختراع ولانك مخترع ولا عندك مكان
ببرنامج نجوم العلوم عيوني
لك راي بس انا واحلا بالعكس انا يشرفني
رايك هذا الشي ما يزعل
مش بزياده كده خلص يعني بحاول بيضغط احمر
احمر احمر طب خليني اشرح الفكره كامله
يعني حتى يعني ما في هم قالوا لي 10 دقائق
حتى العش دقائق ما اخذتها وقت البش البطن
اكثر من مره معناتها لازم يعتذر ول ب
يضيعنا وقتنا ويعمل حاله ويرجع على
بيته مشروعي عباره عن نيو سكور سيستم
مدعوم بقاعده بيانات بحيث انه يسهل على
الاتحادات الرياضه تنظيف
الفعاليات والبطولات لش زعلان انا مش
زعلان يلا
اوكيم جا تقترح اختراع مايك تقنعنا فيه او
وبين غافي ما فرقاني معك تقنعنا يلا بمجال
الرياضه شو المشكله عم تحلها انه نقلل
نسبه الظلم للاعب اوكي وين في ظلم للاعبين
في اثناء الاختيار المسؤولين على اختيار
المنتخب ما بشوفوا 6 لاعب لعبوا في نفس
الوقت طيب فكيف بكون لهم الرانك السيستم
تبعي بحل ها المشكله هلا لعبه التايكوندو
مثلا اوكي بيلبسوا واقيات الكترونيه وقت
اللي انا اسجل نقطه تروح مباشره الى
التابس تبعي بعد كل بطوله بون الي رانكين
معين بنشوف افضل رانكين في اخر ثلاث
بطولات عشان نمثل الوطن في بطولات خارجيه
رح اوقف قدامنا خنا نعطي مثل اعمال حركه
بلعبك التكواندو اللي انت خبير فيها وقلنا
شو هي الداتا اللي انا الكاميرا بدي اعمل
كابتشر لها انا بكون واقف وضعيه القتال
او يجي اللاعب مثلا الكتور احمد هو
لاعب يحاول يقتنص مني يقتنص مني
نقطه في حاله التفادي وارد عليه
الكيك او بتتسجل النق يعني نظرتك لنا هيك
بحس انه انت بهالموضوع عندك تجربه شخصيه
انت مظلوم بالكد ظلموك يعني في
الاختيارات نظرتك فيها هيك يعني ظلم انت
مظلوم بحياتك
[موسيقى]
اكدو نعم بالكد انظلم نعم طيب نحن مستعدين
نصوت وما نظلمه مره ثانيه لغسان نحن ما
بظلم حدا هون شا نبلش
بالفكره طيبه بس ما فيها ايشن ولا حسب ما
شايف غسان انا بقول في دور كبير لتحليل
صوره الكاميرا تخ هل انت حابب تغوص بهذا
التحدي ت نطلع باحلى بروفايل ونصف لاب
حاب حابب حا وانا حابب نقشك هالشيء هون
تفضل مبروك الله يبارك
فيك نحن في نجوم العلوم لا نحب الظلم ولا
الزعل ننصح الجميع بتناول الفطور قبل
مواجهه اللجنه تجنبا للمزاج
[موسيقى]
السيء مشروعي هو عباره عن جهاز يقوم بقياس
جوده البيض بالامكانيات اللي اللي عندي ما
عنديش السنسر في بيض عندك بيض لا لا ما في
بيض ما في بيض كيف ليه هذا بقيس جوده قياس
جوده البيض اوكي مع تقوللي بالامكانيات
البسيطه البسيطه ايه انا عم اقول لك
الامكانيات البسيطه بتسمح لك على القليل
يكون عندك بيضه والله انا انا ما فطرت بكل
حتى اليوم حتى في الصبح جاي من امس الليل
لا تعشيت ولا
افتر فمان عارف طيب اوكي يعني حتى البيضه
مش موجوده لا مش موجوده هذه امكانيات الله
غالب انا حساب روحي جيت بنفطر وان
قبل
هذا رح نتخيل البيضه بمخيلتنا تمام من
الاند يوزر يعني من اللي راح يستخدم هاي
ومتى قصدي مازال ما كملت ن ما كملت ما
كملت استمر في عندي طبعا سميت الجهاز اللي
هو قياس جوده البيض وجوده تخزين المواد
الغذائيه خليك على البيضه اي خلي بس بسالك
انا معلش عندي الحين صاروا سؤالين فخلينا
نسال يعني تفضل ممكن اسال تفضل الحين انت
جربتها كمنتج جربت الاكوشن هذه على بيضه
لا لا اسه عندك شيء لسه يا اخي شو عندك
اسه تفضل طبعا انا عندي عندي بلاتو سيستم
شو عندي بلتوث سيستم بلتوث سيستم بلوتوث
بلوتوث اه بلوتوث تمام وعندي كاميرا اوكي
في الاعلى زين ما شفت انت في السوق شي
يشابهه لان انا قدامي اشوف شي بالضبط
يشابهه اوكي خليني نكمل
الزنا عندنا دقائق احنا عندنا ع
دقائق حتى البيضه موجوده اسمها ادوت كوم
بالضبط نفس الفكره
يعني طيب جاهزين نعطيه
صوتنا
انا مو ب معك
شكرا شكرا جزيلا شكرا شكرا السلام ها الصب
ها
الصب هو داخل علينا زعلان داخل علينا
زعلان صح لا مانيش زعلان
لا جو زعل باد على وجهي غسان ومراد اما
ساره فتناولت فطورها وحضرت بفكره من شانها
تخفيف الزعل والتوتر في الاماكن
[موسيقى]
الضيقه لا لا مو
خايفه احاول ابين انا مو خايفه م قادره ص
خايفه
منه اسمي ساره الانصاري من مملكه البحرين
فين فوبيا من الاماكن المغلقه
[موسيقى]
وهاي شي اعاني منه من وانا صغيره لا لا مو
خايفه انا مو خايفه
منك في انواع كثيره للفوبيا وانا ليوم ما
شفت جهاز يعتبر من الهيلين بروسس حق مرحله
العلاج
للمريض عندي فكره استوحيتها قبل سنتين من
الترينينج انا دخلته اسمها موشن انتلجنس
سمعنا عنه او الذكاء العاطفي حلو عجبني
الترينينج قعد داخل قال لنا المدرب يلا
كلنا نصك عينا ونتخيل ان احنا نطرد
الافكار السلبيه يلا الحين نلقي جسمنا
ونستر خي فمن هاي الترينينج استوحيت بفكره
المشروع اللي هو عباره عن دوم او جهاز
يتكون من سبعه اجهزه مثلا سراوند ساوند
سيستم 3 س بروجكشن سكرين يعني اجهزه بسيطه
مجرد الكومبنيشن مالها بيسوي لنا شيء
يونيك واستخداماتها بتكون على شيء يونيك
شغله الثانيه والاستخدام الثاني للجهاز
باذن الله حق سايكولوجيكال تريتمنت اننا
مثلا الناس اللي فيهم فوبيا مثلا من
الطيران او من الاماكن المغلقه بدل ما
يخذون سبع جلسات مع الدكتور او سبع الى
عشر جلسات نقدر نقلل عدد الجلسات الجهاز
يساعد في عمليه العلاج باذن الله هي مثل
تشمبر يعني اي نفس دوم وفيها بروجكتر
وفيها ساوند وفيها
روائح اضو فيها دراي ايس يصير بالريحه
ايوه اه كل شي في شغله مح بس انا شخصيا
ماني شايف اختراع علمي يعني انا بنجوم
العلوم تعرفيني شو مبرم شايفي حاضره برسير
اي اشوف على شو عم نبرم نحنا هون يعني عن
الساينس وشلون التكنولوجي وشي انوفيت شي
مو موجود في السوق هل هاي المشروع يعتبر
فيه براءه اول شي الكومبنيشن واليو حق
المشين انه اقدر ادخل في مرضى حتى ممكن
ناخذ ستب فرر ندخل طلاب مدارس عشان يشوفون
روحهم في المستقبل ن حلمهم مثلا واحد
مهندس فط يصير مهندس نخليه تشوف روحه ان
هو مهندس عشان يقدر يحقق حلمه
انا انا والله في الاول حسب الريبورت لما
قريتها ما كنتش امبست ولكن من النيشن وم
الاسئله
الحمدلله يعني الحمد لله عندك ضو لا لا
رايك
مهم يعني زملائي القطريين حابين يستضيفون
هون على القلي لمرحله الثانيه بالمجلس
العلمي وهن رح يناقشوا ملفك بالمجلس
العلمي ويدافعوا عنه انا مش قادر ادافع
عنه بالمجلس العلمي انه هذا
اختراع بقى عملتي ازمه هلا بيني وبين
زملائي بس رح نحلها بالمجلس العلمي علميا
ان شاء
الله ف صوتين استاذ فؤاد
[ضحك]
لك اسمي نزار الشلي جيت من تونس هذه ثاني
مره نشارك في البرنامج نجوم العلوم كانت
عندي اربع افكار من الاول سجلتها هي
الاربع افكار ولكن مالقيتش رد من نجوم
العلوم الاول كان ريد يلو الكترونيك كارد
الثاني هو كان جهاز مخصص لكبار السن
الثالث كان هو للمكفوفين الرابع هو كان
للتنميه المستديمه فول بعد كشي خمسه 6ه ف
سبعه ف 8م ف في العاشره يعني لقيت نج
العلوم كلمتني على مشروع اللي هو السبع
مشروع قدمته على البرنامج هيدي السنه كم
اختراع قدمت لنا لانه كيف ما اطلع قدامي
طلبات من تونس يطلع اسمك
بوجي هم كانوا ع افكار ع افكار قدم طلبات
مصمم انه يتعرف عليكم اي ما شاء الله طيب
ع افكار على السريع هيك معلش عنوان عنوان
بدون
شرح
لازمني اذا انت عم تعدهم وخذت نفس طويل اخ
شو عملت فينا تودينا اياهم نحن نقرا وراجع
ونجيب خبره كنت لازم انت تنقي احسن شي هلا
انت نقيت شو
هيدي 3دي سمارت موبايل سكانر سمارت
فون
انت عملت البلاتفورم بحط عليه التليفون
تضلني مهد ايدي انا واطلب تطلب كيف هذا
بتصورهم او بتعم يعني نزل
هنادي التليفون يعمل يعني
ه بيتحرك
بخم هو فقط يعني نقوم بتحريك العجلات في
هذا يعني الاتجاه
ويقوم بالدوران حول يعني الاوبجكت اللي
تحط هنا في
الوسط ليك والله انت انك بتحرق
منيح ان شاء الله خير ه ما تحسبوه على
البروتوتايب
البدائي مشكور جدا انك عملته لوحدك تبرهن
الكونسبت اكثر عملتلنا قد ما فيك تعمل
لوحدك ان شاء
الله انا مبسوط جدا باللي شايفه قدامي هي
التليفون من الكاميرا التكنولوجيا وابر
محو واخذ 3 من الكاميرا اخذ سكان ورا
بعضهم من هلا بقول لك انا حابب اناقشك
بالموضوع العلمي بالمجلس وحابب كمان
ابنيها انا واياك ان شاء الله اول سبورت
دكت فؤاد صرت الحين كلها سبورت حق دكتور
فؤاد اشوف
ثانس بروتوتايب في شغل شاطر
بايديه و براسه مبروك طلع لك ثلاثه خض
بدنا نشوفك
الحمدلله انا عمر احمد من السودان خرجت من
جان خرطوم كليه الهندسه كل شي في
التكنولوجيا فيه كودين فيه الكترونات هذا
الشيء بصير له عادي يعني بتحمس له
كثيرا المشروع هو عباره عن ساعه ذكيه
الساعه تعملك الموشن للاصابع مثلا في
التليفون ممكن افتح الكاميرا فغض غض
دي اوس في مشكله حاليا بس اعطيني
دقتين في خطا بسيط بس
ثواني اتمنى ما يسح هذا الخطا مع
اللجنه اعطيني دقيقتين في مشكله في
الكود مشروع عباره عن ا باند عليها مجموعه
من السنسور وبمكن ان انا اتحكم في اي حاجه
حواليا يعني لو مثلا ابلكيشن ميوزك فانا
ممكن اعلي واوطي الصوت بحركه ايدي في مجال
الجيمين هلعب واقعيه اكتر لو الكركتر اللي
قدامي ماسك مسدس فانا همسك مسدس زيه كده
وه وجه بضرب كان بضرب في
الحقيقه بالمختصر المفيد ان انا عايز
اتحكم في كل حاجه بحاجه
كتير هذا الديفايس اللي اسمه يعني بيعمل
نفس الشيء بس بطريقه اخرى اللي هو عم
يستعمل اي ام جي انت ما بتستعمل الا ام شي
بقى ليش اذا استعملنا طريقتك هي افضل هي
مختلفه ايه بس هي افضل او
اسوا هي افضل لان انا دلوقتي بعتمد على
حيقه ايد بس اي ام جي كمان الحركه ام جي
سنسر اذا استغنيت عنه وطريقتك انت افضل
ليش ت انا افضل ما هو مش بس ده اللي
هيخليني افضل منهم هو كمان الابلكيشن اللي
انا هقدمها شو هي الابلكيشن يلي اختراعك
بخلينا و بيسمح لنا نطبقها
والميو غير ممكن نستعملها فور دات شو هي
لا هو هو مش هيبقى في حاجه انا ممكن
اعملها وهم ما يعملهاش انت بتفهم عربي
انجليزي بص شو
بتفهم باستخدام الاصبع تبعي
خش بن يا اخضر يا احمر وعندي اكر انف انه
بعرف بدي خش
الاحمر معلش مش ض اتكلم معلش والله مش
هينفع بجد بجد بجد والله
ماينفع يعني كده ماينفعش والله
ماينفعش
يا اخي المشتركين ازعجوني والله كل شوي ما
واحد مشتكي وينك انت وتعال حق دكتور فؤاد
شاد علينا خلي يخف خلي مش عارف والله واحد
من شويه قاعد يبكي لحق
للحمام اخر سنه كان احسن مني بكثير يعني
يعني رجع مره ثانيه لطبعه حرام خلينا نروح
نشوف اي موضوع الدكتور يعني يخف المشتركين
وهيبقى عندنا ت دي سي
موتورز سيرد
[موسيقى]
م يعني في عندي جويستيك ولا شو ولا لا هو
عن طريق الموبايل هو خذ اخضر من عندي وما
علك من الدكتور
را تعرفه اه طبعا اكيد دتور
يوفه حكم طيب دكتور خف عليهم انا زعج في
المكتب كل شوي واحد داخل
عليخ بعدين سمع ان كسرت واحده من هذه لحمه
كسرتها من قبل انك شي واحده سبير بمكتبك
جيب حرام عليك احذر ش ما بطونا تشوكلت
لانك مش هون حسك ناكل تشوكلت جايبلي معك
شي ما شاء الله
عليك شكرا بس ها شوف هاي السر انك تخف على
المشتركين رح تصير التحكيم اسهل بكثير
وسلس اكثر شفت شلون تدخل
ش بس اطلع الاقيك
احمر شكرا زياره السيد يوسف اتت في موعدها
خففت من وطاه الابتكارات وزادت حلاوه على
المواجهات على امل ان يستكمل النهار
باضواء
خضراء لطالما قلق اينشتاين من ان تتجاوز
التكنولوجيا التي ننتجها حدود انسانيتنا
نحن نطمن اينشتاين ففي نجوم العلوم كل
ابتكار يروي تجربه انسانيه نعود بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل في التكنولوجيا هل تتحول الاله الى
انسان ام يتحول الانسان الى اله الجواب في
المواجهات التاليه
اسمي نسيم خالد عمري 35 سنه من اصل لبناني
وعايش
بامريكا اختراعي هو تطوير المستعمله ممكن
يستفيد منها تلاميذ الجامعات البروسيه اي
انسان لانه
نسيم
علمته
وقت بس ه رع وبيشتغل وعيش بامريكا نسيم
خبرنا شو هو الاختراع نعم فاذا هذا
الاختراع هو عباره عن تطوير لزر بوينتر
اللي كلنا بستخدمه اسمه ار ه انا عملته
بهذا هلا صار عننا القابليه انه بس تعمل
بروجكشن تستعمل هذا البن وترسم على على
اللوح الموجود عندي ما بدك تغير
البروجكتر هو انك تغير
بزرت كل عندك اياهم بالاندرويد والاي او
اس تقدر تستخدمهم باستخدام هذا القلم
الليي هو ليزر بوينتر جديد انا بسميه وشو
هلا في اب بدنا نشوف الامج هلا ما في اب
لشو عملت كل ه الهارد
وير حبيت بس ان بدل ما احكيك انا ان سبيس
واقوللك شابر واقوللك انه كيف يشتغل يعني
شت عند انتراكتف بروجكتر وعندك وايرلس ب
نعم وانت عاملهم انتجريشن مع بعض الروكت
هي البروجكتر التقليديه اللي مستعملها ما
فيها شي خصوصي لبروجكت القلم مع الاب
والليس الانتراكتيف بروج انتراكتف بروجكت
اللي هو اليوم بصير انبوت منه ه هي الفكره
بالضبط ليش قدرت ت شرحتها كثير اري كيف
الوايرلس بين بيشتغل الموجود بالسوق
والوايرلس بين هيك بيشتغل في ابلكيشن
السكرين ا سف بكون انتراكتف بتقدر تعمل
هالموضوع هذا انا بدي اخلي السيستم مثل ما
هو وتقدر تستخدم وتعمل ه القابليه هذه ما
راح تلاقي ليزر بوينتر بتعمل هذا الموضوع
اللي انا عم بقوللك عنه طيب جاهزين تلونه
اي انا جاهز لانه جاي من امريكا لونه ابيض
بلا لون ما بعرف شو صارلك زمان بعيد عن
مست بدنا شويه لون بوجهك 14 ساعه
طاير تفضل طيب
ما وانا كثير سعيد انه مش صوتي هو اللي
بيعمل الفرق بالتوفيق لاه خضر
انا بحب اقول بس جمله بالاخر انا فخور ان
تلمي لدكتور مراد وعرفت انه اليوم لاني
تلميزه حيكون اقسى علي من غيري يعني فجرب
تكون
جاهز وهي هي اذا بدك هذا الحبر من هدي
المحبره يعني انا متعلم على ايده يعني
فعرفت را يجلدني يعني مسؤوليه كبيره يلا
موفق
شكرا
ري
يس
يس اطيني دقيقتين في مشكله في
الكود في توتر حاصل في مشكله في الكود
بسيطه ماشي اعالج
فيها اوكي تتكلم في سبع دقائق حطكم غاق
للاسئله فكره المشروع بتاعتي شنو المشروع
هو سمارت وتش ساعه ذكيه انه الساعه دي
تستطيع تكت للموشن بتاع الاصابع تتعرف على
حركه الاصابع تتحكم في التلفاز ان ارفع
الصوت اتنقل بين القنوات اتحكم في المكيف
فقط بحركه اليد نحن نتحدث عن عصر جديد عصر
ما بعد الهواتف النقاله ف بحركه اليد فقط
بقبضه اليد سوف تفتح الكاميرا اذا شايفين
عند عامل سبريد تغط الصوره هذه الساعه
اللي عندك لا هذه مجرد
موديل كونس اناي ملزم اللي قلتلنا اه
بتحكي انت سبع دقاق بعدين نح بحكي صح وين
ص سب دقاق تقريبا خلصوا كم سع صاروا سته
هلا طيب تفضل
الا كنت حاسس في ضغط علي انه ما احكي ولا
كلمه عجبني طريقتك كل هذا تقدر اتحك
بطريقه
اليد ش اتحكم حت في اجهزه الاضاءه في جهاز
التكييف شركه
الكهربا اريت كنت فيك تعمل هيك مثلا وترد
تعمل ري لشن صارت معنا مني ساعه من زميل
لك طرح نفس الشي وانا حاسس اريت فيني اعمل
ر لللاسف ما مشي حاله انا ببشرك انه
عملوها قبلك بالهند فوت جوجل
هلا بروكت على هيك هيك بتلاقي الك موجود
ممكن
تعليقق علق انا عم حاول رفش اوك
جميل اوكي
اسف التفاصيل بتختلف شو معنا يعلق واحد
يعني بضل معلق العيد نفس الحديث بقولوا
علق التيب هيدا القديم بتذكر التيب علق
ايوه ما تعلق قوله وامشي خلص اسمعنا رايك
ما تعيدها مره ثانيه فيك تعمل هالشيء
وفيني اشتريه اليوم انا ومره ثانيه بيجيني
حدا من السودان ومصر بيقول عندي هالاختراع
بدي البسه واعمل له ريموت كنترول
سك
موجود اعطوني احمر بس ان شاء الله حواص في
المشروع واثق ان المشروع حينجح ف مش فارغ
معي المسابقه
في تصفيات الحوسبه وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
تطبيقات ذكيه من شانها التاثير في قضايا
تعنى بالحياه
والموت مشروعي عباره عن جاز سلندر سيستم
هناك كثير من المشاكل تواجه خاصه مربات
البيوت انه ما يعرفون ليفل الجاز الجاز
سلندر ويصير ليكج بسبب هشي تصير كثير من
الحرائق فانا ابتكرت هالشي ان يكون عندنا
جاز سلندر سيستم كان مونيتر ذا ف جاز
سلندر موبايل اب انا اقدر اتاكد هل انا
سكرت الغاز او لا في حال اني انا كنت خارج
المنزل هلا انت جاي من الامارات على قطر
اي وحظك منيح معنا اثنين قطريه مرحبا فيهم
وهنا عاصمه الغاز
بالعالم خلي النقاش يصير معهم وانا ح
اتسمع والاخر شكل يعني راي اوكي انا
بالنسبه لي عندنا في حينه قطر بالضبط نفس
العمل وفي
عنكر عنش
تسكر موجوده
مثلا على الماركت الان والحل موجودفي نشت
عندش الاشياء شي واحد واحد واحد بس
نحن اللي شفتهم شفت في جا ديكت بس هي عم
تقول انه ديتكشن بخبرك على الاب وين ما
تكون موجوده مع الاب مع الاب انا ما شفتها
مش موجو طيب خم اوعمل معي
مقابله عندنا شركه اسمها صمام هم مقتنعين
بس مو مقتنعين ان هي مو
موجوده بكتور احمد شفتهم كل
هون
مبوط مجمع كذا شغله مع
بعضهم معلش انا شفت نفس الفكره عندنا في
الحاضنه فانا ماي ماي
فوت اوي
ثكو والله سميره انا يعني مش مقتنع 100%
متردد شوي ولكن ماعتقد ان في شيء اضافه
وفي شيء زايد فانا مك تعطيه الضو اخضر
اخضر ثانكيو هلا انت على حدود يعني
من قطر للامارات على الحدود
اوكي
حابب اقوللك انه بدي اناقش ملفك بالمجلس
العلمي
[تصفيق]
مبروك جهاز ايمكس يعالج مشكله تعاني منها
جميع المجتمعات وجميع الدول الا هي مشكله
نسيان اطفال داخل المركبات يعني عم نحكي
نن سيناريو انه واحد نسي الطفل داخل
السياره قفل وراح ايو شو اللي بميز هذا عن
كل شي في موجود بالسوق انا هلا فيني افتح
هذا كمبيوتر وبشتريه بعد 24 ساعه بون عندك
بمسقط اتحداك ان ما تحصل نفس الميزات ما
هيدي هي عم حااول ارشك انا شو هي المييزات
اللي بتميز هذا الجهاز عن غيره وان شاء
الله تكون تفاضليه مش لوراق ان شاء الله
بس انت اطني مساحه عشان احكيه بدي اعطيك
مساحات تفضل طيب اول شي الجهاز خفيف الوزن
يسهل تركيبه في سقف السياره بكل بساطه
ثانيا لون الجهاز فاتح لكي لا يمتص حراره
بالتالي لا يؤدي الى قراءه خاطئه في ميزه
حلوه انه لونه ابيض والله يمتص الشمس وهذا
شي منيح يعني خلصت مساحتك بدنا نعطي مساحه
لزملائي شو
رايك في جهاز اسمه تومي تصور انت هلا هذا
الجهاز لونه ابيض وسميته حمدان كيوت انا
اليوم فيني اشتري لك
جهاز يمكن ما بيشبه هذا بتمنى ما يشبه هذا
احسن من هذا بس في فرق بينك وبينه انت ماك
عم تشوفه مزه الخنجر يعني ك سم عربيه سمع
عربيه يعني تميز الجهاز صنع في عمان ايوه
من جهاز ابيض الى مكعب ملون هل سيتمكن
احمد من تحدي اللجنه في حل المكعب في خلال
ثانيه انا اسمي احمد الحسن عمري 20 سنه
جيت خصيصا على قطر من الاردن الك جزء من
حياتي مش مجرد لعبه بدها مانم معينه وال
لازم امشي
عليها مين معنا هون احمد احمد من الاردن
بك خبرنا شو الاختراع اللي جايبه سيمز
لايك متعلق به الكيوب اللي حامله يعني
مايبي لانه 3 دي لانه 3 دي طيب هلا بدنا
نشوف شو علاقه هيدا الكيوب بهال الجلوب
الحلو باحمد اعطينا شو الاختراع اوكي تمام
الجهاز بعرض 360 درجه اوكي على السيرفس
كامل انت ممكن تشوف شاشه كامله تتحكم فيها
بالستر كنترول ممكن انه احنا لما بدنا
مثلا نعرض عضو معين في جسم الانسان القلب
شرايين بمجرد ما يمسكها الدكتور اللي بده
يعلم الطلاب اللي عنده ححطها عندهم فرجيه
كيف القلب شو مكونات القلب انت شفت هذا
البرودكت اللي انت قايل عنه بالابلكيشن
اسمه سفيري او شيء اه ايوه بالضبط كيف
بتقارن سفيري للي عم تقترحه سفيري ما فهم
السوق نعم سفيري ما فهم شو حاجه السوق هو
ما فهم شو حاجه السوق ايوه بالضبط معقول
انت هلا طلعت افهم من كل هول الناس كل
هالشركات كل هال
الجمعات قلنا ليش المستخدم العادي بده
جهاز ياخذه معه بده جهاز ما بده يضل ب
انفنت وحده سفير يعني مباع منها كثير انا
اولادي العبوه بالصفير تمام سفيري لازم
يضل ثابت ب مكان معين له زي هيك قاعده
وكبير ومثبت عليها وممنوع تتحركوا هذا
ستاند الون ديفايس هاند هيلد ممكن تمسكه
وتروح فيه وين ما بدك وبنفس الوقت تعرض
عليه كل الاشياء اللي بتحتاجها طيب وشو
علاقه الكيوب بكل اللي اسمعني كيوب
بالنسبه لي حياتي كلها ف
بحس اذا شي لازم اعم لازم يكون 3دي الكيوب
اذا بدي اعمل ها اول تطبيق ممكن اعمله انه
تحل اوكيم جاي من الاردن حابي تفيه لفتره
اطول بقطر ولا بدي يرجع على الاردن انا
حابه الصراحه تعط ضو الضو
الاخضر انا شايف حالي انه في
شي هذا الكوب اللي قدامك احم وشوف قديش
بدك تترجع تحل لي اياه كله وانا را حيلك
قديش بدك 30 ثانيه 30 ثانيه
[موسيقى]
بلش
خلصها يلا يلا يلا يلا يلا يلا مبروك اهلا
وسهلا فيك على
الدوحه شكرا كثير بسال تري كيوب انت ماي
هيرو لسه في كثير اشياء غير هذا الكيوب
بفرجيكم اياها ان شاء الله يلا ان شاء
الله خير الحمد لله لاثه
اخضر يا اللي عجبني فيه ان هي سوي ايدياز
و سمارت يعني سمارت بدكم اياه
بالدوحه الدوحه ما يطلع من الدوح انا معكم
بدنا اياه
بالدوحه مشاهدينا الكرام ما كنا لنلتقي
اليوم ولا حتى الاسبوع الماضي ولا المقبل
لولا هذا الانجاز البشري الكبير المسمى
بتكنولوجيا المعلومات اليوم حصلنا على
ابتكارات عربيه واعده في هذا المجال وفي
حلقه التصفيات المقبله نفط غاز طاقه بشريه
لا متناهيه ما عليكم الا الترقب والانتظار
الى حينها نبقى على تواصل على ستارز كوم
فيسبوك انستغرام وتويتر ايضا تجدون نجوم
العلوم اينما كان من حولكم اما الان
استودعكم الله مثل ما على الحب التقينا
على الود دائما نلتقي في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ا
[موسيقى]
oh